General Petraeus is a regular guest on
DW the four-star general served in Iraq
and Afghanistan and was the head of the
CIA before he resigned in 20 2012. it's
an honor to talk with him today about
the war in Ukraine in the global impact
in such a crucial moment
General Petraeus National Security
adviser Jake Sullivan just said that
there would be I quote him here
catastrophic consequences for Russia if
they use nuclear weapons in Ukraine what
would the consequences be I thought it
was very heartening to hear frankly
because what it indicates is that
the U.S and presumably our allies have
been thinking this through and more
importantly communicating with Russia uh
that such a use of nuclear weapons would
bring about this again catastrophic
response which I would assume would
include targeting of you of Russian
forces in Ukraine and on the Black Sea
um and it would I am quite confident be
very very devastating to Russian forces
there let's keep in mind as well though
that just the cost benefit analysis here
for Vladimir Putin who of course is in
an incredibly desperate situation uh and
we can talk about that in a moment but
to use technical nuclear weapons would
actually not reverse Russia's fortunes
on the battlefield it would
be very destructive very lethal in a
specific area on that battlefield but it
would not reverse this reality that
confronts Russia and that is the real
new development I think in Ukraine
which is demonstrated by the Ukrainian
successful offensive but what is behind
that is the fact that the ukrainians
have decisively
won the Battle of force generation in
other words from the very beginning they
mobilized completely and now this
country of less than a third the
population of Russia uh has a much
larger Army in the field in Ukraine it
is vastly better equipped of course 15.1
billion dollars worth of military
hardware and ammunition and assistance
from the United States alone and plenty
more from our NATO allies and other
Western countries throughout the world
and now they are bringing these new
forces and capabilities to bear in a
very effective manner on the battlefield
there's nothing that Russia can do to
reverse this situation General that some
people say just because of that and as
you just mentioned because uh Putin
might be so desperate that it could be
likely that he uses nuclear weapons
again do you think it is likely and what
would it mean it is certainly a
possibility that possibility has to be
taken very seriously I don't think it is
that likely but again something so
dangerous uh and horrific uh does have
to be taken seriously clearly as Jake
Sullivan indicated we are taking it very
seriously and more importantly we are
communicating with Russia uh and with
the leadership there presumably
um in a general way what the response
would be to obviously deter them to
dissuade them from taking this decision
if anything it will unite Ukraine even
more against Russia it will unite NATO
even more against Russia it will result
in additional very very toughest
sanctions uh Financial economic personal
uh this could be the moment where Russia
has finally declared a state sponsor of
Terror perhaps even war crimes uh
charges are levied against uh Putin this
I think this takes the gloves off in
terms of the western response this
partial mobilization what it has done is
uh
prompted demonstrations all kinds of
disruptions around Russia what does it
mean that he's experienced such a
backlash in his own country Vladimir
Putin certainly this has brought out
enormous demonstrations in Russia
um the size that we haven't seen for a
very long period of time uh and of
course he feared this this is why he
hesitated as long as he did noting that
you know he's already carried out three
uh in a sense partial mobilizations
before this They carried out one that
was before the The Invasion for the
training they they did a subsequent one
and then they had a more recent one
which I struck me as just flat ludicrous
it was basically to tell every Russian
Republican the Federation to provide a
battalion's worth of soldiers I mean
that's not how you create uh trained
equipped organized cohesive well-led and
and so forth capable organizations
that's sort of what we did in the
Revolutionary War you know in the in our
hour of greatest need where every town
came up with its own militia
um this is not how you create modern
capable
combat forces so again he is in a very
very serious and very desperate
situation and again I'm not sure how
widespread the recognition is that this
is actually irreversible for him
assuming and it's a good assumption that
the U.S and other NATO and Western
countries will continue to provide the
very robust Military Support that we
have been giving to Ukraine and keep it
I would like to come back to that in a
minute sir if I might I would like to
have like one question about
um the so-called referenda so the G7
already
stated that they won't accept the
outcome
um of the so-called referenda in the
occupied regions in eastern Ukraine what
impact does this have on the military
strategy
um none on the Ukrainian side candidly
uh they are not going to acknowledge
that this is part of Russia uh any more
that they'll acknowledge that what was
seized back in 2014 as part of Russia
um and indeed of course they've
conducted strikes and operations against
Russian forces in Crimea
um and there was no discernible uh
response to that uh by Russia as if it
had been on their territory or something
like that the real issue here uh is I
think that Putin wants to complete this
in time for the fall conscript uh
recruitment drive that goes on every
year in Russia and this will now be part
of Russia so now they can try to round
up uh men of military age in these new
quote Russian republics or whatever they
will describe them as again that's not
going to produce
capable weltering and well-equipped
organized forces it'll create more
bodies but bodies aren't how you combat
a force that is now shown to be as
capable uh and is well equipped uh and
increasingly uh professional Ukrainian
forces General Petraeus give me some
help in understanding the debate about
tanks Germany's criticized still
criticized continuously criticized so
harshly what about France and Great
Britain in that regard well the Leo part
2 is a great tank
um and you know it's been
the reason people buy it is because it
is a terrific tank
um
the challenge when it comes to the M1
tank produced by the US is that it is so
heavy
um and it is so difficult to maintain
that I think they're just serious
reservations that we're going to get
this 70 ton plus uh Beast you know this
is basically a jet engine surrounded by
heavy armor with a huge cannon on it
keep in mind it's a 1500 horsepower
basically jet turbine this is not a
diesel
engine you know traditional
and having had lots of m1s in units
under my command in combat I can tell
you that the maintenance requirements
are enormous uh you have to have all
kinds of Diagnostics very highly trained
technicians mechanics and everything is
so heavy they're literally much heavier
than uh any other tank in the world so
you have to then also not not only do
you have to have an M1 tank you have to
have a an M1 tank recovery vehicle which
is of course on an M1 tank chassis
um if it breaks out in the eastern part
of the country you're gonna have to get
it back out to Poland to repair it well
then that means you have to have uh a
lowboy that is sufficient to carry a 70
ton uh tank all that distance do the
bridges stand up to this can the roads
take it
um again these are the concerns I think
when it comes to the M1 and and
curiously Germany wants the U.S to
provide just a few first so that that
will validate and then they can provide
theirs I think my sense is the leopard
would be more easily maintained just
coming back from Germany if it would
have met a German chancellor or could
have met German Chancellor Olaf Schwartz
would you have told him come on send
over some Leo Parts would this be your
recommendation I would never disclose
what I would say to a political leader
even as a retired four-star in general
then let me phrase my question
differently should Germany send Leo
parts to Ukraine well what I would like
to see first frankly is scour for every
t-72 t64 t80 that might be in the
arsenals of NATO countries still most of
those have been provided to Ukraine by
this point in time but there may still
be others the ukrainians know how to
operate them maintain them repair them
have the ammunition for them and all the
rest of that and then with a promise to
backfill those with leopard twos or m1s
or what have you uh that I think is the
first uh course of action let's keep in
mind by the way that I I think it is
accurate to say that Ukraine has vastly
more tanks now than it had at the start
of the war because it is captured about
a third or more of the Russian systems
that um that they took out again I I
don't want to get too caught up on this
particular issue because you start to
lose sight of how enormous these
assistance has been let me give you just
a tiny bit of math just about heavy
artillery so the United States alone has
provided 126 155 millimeter howitzers
these are heavy artillery pieces
and trucks to carry them because the
Hydraulics don't work all that well
without that
then we're providing I think we're
almost about 750
000 rounds of artillery at this point in
time for that particular Cannon now you
can only put about 40 to 45 rounds per
five ton truck so do the math and
realize how many tens of thousands of
trucks have to go from the border with
Poland out to the east or the South uh
just to get those to the artillery
pieces but that gives you a sense of how
massive these numbers are and again as
somebody who was part of an invasion of
a country is a two-star general and shot
a fair amount of artillery uh and
Rockets and and missiles these numbers
are just mind-boggling I mean yes it's a
very different War to be sure
um but what has been provided is just
truly incredible and in a subset of both
the artillery rounds and the rocket
rounds that we're providing for the
multiple launch rocket system we have
provided are so precise that they can
land on a dinner table these rounds cost
over a hundred thousand dollars a piece
and I think we've provided roughly 1000
and or so of those from the artillery
and maybe a light number for the Rockets
this is a subset of those because again
uh the cost of these is so enormous in
in our own arsenals our only uh so big
well what does Ukraine need most right
now well I think an area of real
emphasis has to be additional air and
ballistic missile defenses uh because
the one reality that is still very Stark
for Ukraine is that while Russia can can
no longer take appreciable territory it
is likely to lose much if not all of
what they have seen since 24 February
with tough fighting to be sure
what Russia can and is doing uh is to
carry out essentially punishing strikes
they can punish Ukraine with missiles
and Rockets uh and they have been doing
that and they're going after civilian
infrastructure in particular power
generation power transmission even
hospitals in some cases uh water
supplies all of this to make life
difficult increasingly difficult for
Ukrainian citizens
in those areas that are within range of
these different capabilities and of
course Russia has some that are very
very long range
um so that is the that's the brutal
reality for Ukraine and its leadership
just as Putin has to face this brutal
reality that he's lost the first
generation War and the implications of
that are that is Russia his forces are
going to lose uh the vast vast majority
if not all of what they have gained
since 24 February when that does take
shape I think another important element
will be the NATO countries
pledging uh to ensure the security of
Ukraine and perhaps actually inviting
Ukraine uh to apply for membership in
NATO oh you would recommend that that
Ukraine at some point should join NATO I
think that that moment is approaching I
think that again a lesson of this is our
concern for moscow's for the Kremlin
sensitivities about Ukraine being part
of the West part of a NATO uh Alliance
the EU
um we were very sensitive to that it
didn't turn out well and we cannot allow
such a situation again keep in mind as
well
that for the success of the
Reconstruction of Ukraine the success of
some kind of Marshall Plan for Ukraine
there will have to be a security
guarantee or it will not uh it will not
uh succeed you will not be able to
rebuild it you certainly won't be able
to attract outside investors of any size
without a sense that again the security
is going to be preserved keep in mind
that really the the most important
contribution the U.S made to the
Reconstruction of European countries in
the wake of World War II was actually
not the funding of the Marshall Plan as
important as that was don't get me wrong
but really it was the security guarantee
that the U.S provided there is no doubt
that the support from the United States
from President Biden was outstanding
um will this change with the midterms or
the possible
no I think uh it's very uh important to
recognize that on Capitol Hill for
example among the biggest champions of
support for Ukraine is
the minority leader of the Senate
Senator Mitch McConnell a leading voice
on this
um together of course with the majority
leader but that made me very very
clearly there is strong bipartisan
support I think we may see actually a
further increment of additional support
there is discussion the rumors that
perhaps Senator Lindsey Graham might be
the one that Champions this is another
very strong supporter of what the White
House is doing in this regard he'd like
to see them do more in some cases to be
sure but again you've got very very
strong support in the Senate and also in
the house uh in the minority parties uh
supporting the White House in this
effort so I don't think that the
midterms will change this there will be
enough support no matter who controls uh
which house and given uh President Biden
still in the White House do you have any
estimates how long this war might go on
their new numerous factors one of the
ones that I'm watching most closely has
to do with Russian morale
does do individual soldiers do small
units do large units
surrender Melt Away collapse this is
going to be a tougher winter for the
Russian soldiers than it will be for the
ukrainians the ukrainians are on their
own soil with a very supportive
citizenry around them doing whatever
they can to support the Russians are in
areas where the citizens hate them
they're occupiers they have brought
terrible violence and destruction to the
areas that they control there are
increasing actions by essentially
essentially guerrilla warfare Insurgent
Warfare terrorism behind the lines
and some of them are having their tours
extended they're not even sure what
they're really fighting for the
ukrainians are fighting this is their
war of independence the Russian this is
a war of aggression and increasingly
they're going to hear as Citizens and
the Streets back home opposing what
Putin is doing as well so the question
is in those circumstances given that
context given how impressive now the
Ukrainian forces are doing on the
battlefield they're about to surround
another important city in that uh Nexus
between hark even and luhan's Lyman
which is a critical location which I
think the Russians will have to withdraw
their forces from or lose them as this
continues you know what point uh do
these soldiers ask whether they want to
be the last person to die in this war
for their country
and I just don't see the prospect that
this partial mobilization is going to
generate much effective combat
capabilities certainly not in the near
term and probably not even in the
midterm so
um as that realization settles in among
Russian soldiers
how long can they continue to fight
effectively uh do units again crumble
and then collapse but it's very very
hard to feel that from afar it's
actually hard even in battle I've been
in some during the fight to Baghdad
where all of a sudden the enemy
collapsed after several days of tough
fighting and you didn't you look back
and and there was no specific Catalyst
or action that precipitated they just
ran out of uh they culminated uh
probably physically mentally
um when is that point it is very
difficult to say but at as that point
begins to arrive as ukrainians achieve
further success I do think at some point
there's going to have to be some move
again towards discussions towards
negotiations because at the end of the
day president zielinski is right the
resolution will come through
negotiations
but as I mentioned earlier a critical
element undergirding that I think will
need to be a security guarantee uh from
the from the West General Patrice thank
you so much and I'm looking forward to
keep this conversation going thank you
always a pleasure thank you